[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode of
ALS
now I know it's been a long time and I'm
gonna go into why I'm gonna it's gonna
be a video inside a video Oh
inception we're gonna do that and you
get a chance to see exactly what took so
long
mainly I had a basement problem but also
I had a statue situation and I'm gonna
show you that statue situation while I
go over it and explain stuff to you guys
so I can get a better understanding of
how most of the stuff goes you know
what's shelving to get and stuff like
that um so cool we here for now remember
I left you guys on a cliffhanger
therefore that guy Sabretooth
Victor Creed I know you guys like okay
how you gonna give me pick Tikrit
save it to what I'll giving me Wolverine
first
well little-known fact
save the two actually is a villain of
iron fist
saber-tooth was introduced and I am fist
number 14 please we came out August 1977
now saber-tooth really wasn't a mutant
at first from the brilliant minds of
Chris Claremont and John Byrne the
artist which is one of my favorite
artists and the reason why he's one of
my favorite artists because he was
drawing iron fist they came up with this
character who was supposed to be a
serial killer you know but then they
made him a mutant later and he became a
part of different mutants groups later
and then they attached in the Wolverine
a lot of you guys might think that um he
is a wolf wings daddy that's not the
case his history and his law is very
convoluted so the movie the pictures of
the character I never thought they got
an actual representation of the
character I always thought that the
character was either under sized or
underwhelming he's on a scale of a
carnage like you see in spider-man he is
a serial killer
he's a maniac he's a mass murderer you
know and for you to delve deep into that
character you have to go into his
miniseries which they put out which was
very good it was done properly so if you
get a chance go to your local comic book
store or go online on Amazon and order
of the sabre-tooth miniseries which was
drawn perfectly and the storyline was
very good fleshed out the character a
little bit more like you know Marvel
does
I never thought that you know Fox did a
great job of the with the character
hopefully now that he's an MCU that are
actually you know Kevin Feige and these
guys got ahold of the character back you
can actually see a proper representation
of this character this character is by
far one of the most interesting villains
that she can um delve into because his
motivations aren't financial his
motivations already power his
motivations is simply to create mayhem
and destruction all right um all right
guys before I shoot out this video and
let y'all see exactly what happened with
the other video and you guys to see that
this statue in all its glory this is a
premium format it's mixed-media it has
to switch out heads also I have one of
the heads it's pretty custom it has a
clear resin and the mouth like saliva is
dripping out and remember when I tell
you about mixed-media guys this one it's
the whole body is in materials and cloth
so you know I keep it in a glass case
because I love it over a period of time
you know this mixed-media stuff tends to
fade and I noticed as colors seemed a
little bit faded a little bit not too
much but um sideshow also put out
another statue same pose but not mix
media and then they also did another
saber tooth which - saber tooth I'm
going to probably pick up along with the
wolf ring that goes with it is a
companion piece
might have those like face-off on the
door Rama on this next room that I'm
working on that's over there so alright
guys um this is the part where I'm going
to actually pay if you liked the video
please like follow and subscribe and
also go to the Lords of gaming net where
we have the later the latest news on all
that's going on in the industry some
news that we have on sports with a
combat talk with the king that's myself
and also the looter shooter news with
the last word with low kognito any
bonta's right now destiny is at all-time
high you have great games and like the
division also you have apex legends out
there tearing up the streets and you
know we have a lot of opinion pieces
that's up there so please go to Lords of
gaming garnett and also like Bob will
describe subscribe yeah I understand
it's is getting back into the swing of
things guys but I'm here for you no
matter what we're gonna work through
everything so I can bring you these
premium statues because I get boxes
delivered to me daily and um all I'm
doing is getting this content out to you
guys so again see you next week where I
might give you somebody just trying to
take over the world
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]